créature de la pop culture inspire des
croyances d'Haïti ou d'Afrique les
zombies tel qu'on les connaît dans les
films ces pauvres bouces pourrai bien
être atteints de deux maladies bien
distincte le syndrome de Cotar et
l'encéphalite léthargique la première
est une pathologie psychiatrique aussi
appelée walking corp syndrome le patient
qu'on est atteint est persuadé d'être
déjà mort et immortel à la fois que ses
organes sont en train de pourrir et
qu'il est danné voir possédé la seconde
maladie est une infection virale du
cerveau dont les symptômes sont un état
comateux avec diminution des réactions
au stimulation
une faiblesse musculaire avec
tremblement et
rigidité une inversion du rythme jour
nuit des troubles du comportement mais
aussi un mutisme et une bonne
phingite tout ça on a pas un zombie